hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
uh december 28 2020 what's going on how
are you it's the last
monday of the [ __ ] 2020
sorry hey um
you know there's a lot of people right
now saying you know talking a lot of
[ __ ] about 20 20.
you know thank god this [ __ ] year's
over
um if you think that the beginning of
january is gonna be any better than the
end of december just because the number
went from 20 to 21 you're sadly mistaken
all right it's not about years
okay it's not about years
um i don't know what it's about i don't
know i think next year
is going to be [ __ ] amazing though i
really do i just
i want to see how this whole thing plays
out okay so we got dum-dum is leaving
office and now we have a dude who i
think has dementia a warmonger with
dementia
is coming in and they're both liberal
larry's but for some reason they love
keeping people of color in prison i
don't know what non-violent
in prison so this is gonna be a really
weird year
um we're gonna see and then the
vaccine's coming out and then you got
all these people that are going to take
it and then people say don't take it and
then it's going to be all this amazing
misinformation
presented as fact it's going to be on
the internet
um i don't know all i know is my doctor
took it so
you know i mean how big is this
conspiracy it's that big
that even doctors are in on it that that
i can go see
not like the uh the bilderberg group
doctors
you know the ones that keep dick cheney
alive
it's all the way down to my doctor that
i can just call them up yeah come on
down tuesday
i'll take a look at your ticker
um we shall see um oh billy salad face
oh billy salad fate's been crushing it
oh billy head of lettuce oh that was a
weird burp did you hear that
that's that one where you're like
inhaling and you still burp
so it like goes off inside inside your
body
you know like one of those maniacs in
the military finds a bomb
and they put that thing around it and
they get it to go up we get it bill we
get it we also burp
um anyway uh
it's raining out here it never rains
in california remember that song but boy
don't they warn you hit pause man it
pours
yeah i went outside and uh i did some
dad [ __ ]
i went out and i stood in the driveway
you know
legs spread apart like a state trooper
arms crossed just watching the water
coming down the driveway making sure
it's going down the drains
clearing out the leaves and all of that
[ __ ] um
this is an amazing time of year out here
in la is it rains
a lot and uh all of la
gets as green as like you know portland
oregon or seattle
it's amazing and it lasts for about two
and a half weeks and that's when they
take
all the pictures for taurus to come to
la
you know because it gets all green the
rain knocks all the
all the dust all the dirt all the smog
out of the air it's crystal clear and
then they take that picture of downtown
l.a
with mount the snow capped mount baldy
in the background
and i used to look at that all the time
going where the [ __ ] is that
mountain i've never seen a snow capped
mountain out here in l.a
ever it's this time of year that's when
they do it
there's like a [ __ ] it's like a lunar
eclipse you know what happens like once
a year doesn't it
is that what happens for all you space
people out there all you people into
outer space
what's wrong with down here man huh what
are you running from
oh you nerds looking through your
telescope huh maybe they'd like me out
there
um i'm [ __ ] with you
um yeah so i am committed to having a
salad a day
in um in 2021 i'm just gonna be crushing
that and i'm telling you all you gotta
do is you just gotta have your toppings
all set up make your chicken
cube it stick it in your tupperware all
right cube you beat you [ __ ] cube
everything
cucumbers tomatoes the whole [ __ ]
thing you get those little cherry
tomatoes little
[ __ ] round ones and you just have it
ready to go
you wash it chop up your lettuce rinse
it off wash it
put it in the [ __ ] thing right dry it
off and it's just ready to go
so when your brain's going hey man like
why don't we have something like
[ __ ] yummy man we've been good right
you can quickly put together a salad and
eat that and beat down that [ __ ]
thing that wants you to go eat a cookie
or some [ __ ] or maybe i'm just talking
about myself maybe you guys don't have a
problem
huh maybe you went out and you bought
that new [ __ ] full-length mirror
gym thing have you seen that dumbass
thing that stupid-ass [ __ ] thing
how [ __ ] dumb are people who are
gonna buy that thing
it's a full-length like skinny flat
screen tv
with a personal trainer because you're
too much of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] to motivate yourself i can't
do it alone i need somebody
talking to me all of these [ __ ]
jerk-offs
haven't you learned anything with your
[ __ ] flat screen tv
you go down to best buy and that [ __ ]
geek squad
douche talk [ __ ] again oh man this
thing's gonna crush it at the super bowl
your super bowl party everybody's gonna
love it
it is so [ __ ] clear and three years
later
three years later you can't hook
anything up to it because it's
completely 100 obsolete all of those
[ __ ] things
all of those [ __ ] full-length [ __ ]
whatever you call those goddamn things
mirror mirror on the wall
jim things right those things are all
going to be in the ocean
every [ __ ] one of them within five
years because then they're gonna have
the next one
oh my god have you gotten the new mirror
mirror on the wall
jim this one's horizontal oh yeah and i
can hook my [ __ ] you know my blender
up to it
be making a smoothie as i'm doing my
last reps
who's your favorite virtual trainer
the [ __ ] so you can't just go do some
burpees
you all you really need is a yoga mat
a prison workout and then if you eat
right you don't need all of that [ __ ]
all right but everybody wants the pizza
everybody wants the cookies and the
[ __ ] shakes and then you lie to
yourself going like oh i burned it off
oh did you do how long you got to be on
a [ __ ] elliptical to burn off an oreo
cookie shake
okay and don't [ __ ] with me because i
live this i live this every week
do you know what an elliptical really is
it's just it's just
a it's just something that wears out
your joints
at the end of the day you know in the
short run you know you're burning
calories and blah blah but in the long
run
all it's doing is like the people who
make that i bet also have degrees in
like
knee and hip replacements or no people
they got a piece of that action
because the reality is is if you just
ate right and you went for a [ __ ]
walk
and you did some push-ups and some
sit-ups right
some other [ __ ] wouldn't you be fine
do you really need some [ __ ]
i don't know space 1999 [ __ ] whatever
the [ __ ] jesus christ that's like 20
years old now
remember that show in the 70s like can
you imagine 1999
cars flying can you imagine that
i like when people [ __ ] about that
where are all the flying cars oh yeah
well
people are too stupid to [ __ ] you
can't give people flying
cars they crash the ones on the ground
you want him up in the air
[Music]
[Laughter]
by the way that jerk-off out here in his
jet pack has been
him or her has been going up again
unfucking believable
that person should get [ __ ] 20 years
in jail for that
considering like a flock of birds
took down sully's airplane can you
imagine what a human being in a jet pack
would do
if he [ __ ] went into the engine of a
goddamn airplane
i guess you'd need two of them right to
knock out both engines but whatever
you could take [ __ ] do such
significant damage to one of the wings
could kill 600 people on the way out
here 600
fatties with the [ __ ] mirror mirror
on the wall what is the name of that
[ __ ] gym
um don't buy that [ __ ] thing that
thing is gonna be this [ __ ] for about
three months
and knowing most people then you're not
gonna use it you're gonna start using it
as an actual mirror to look into to see
how fat you're getting
and then how do you throw it out
where do you put it
it's not going to help you none of that
[ __ ]
they got all of that's all like the big
thing now
these [ __ ] they got that peloton bike
you start riding the tour de france
i'm in a bike race right in my living
room
you know they make bicycles
get on a bicycle and ride down the
street and you know what i've had the
same bicycle since 1982. i still have it
and it still [ __ ] works i can tell
you something about those peloton bikes
they're all gonna be in the [ __ ]
ocean
all of them in the ocean within five
years
it's not compatible anymore your bicycle
isn't compatible your [ __ ] legs are
still shaped the way they're shaped
right
yeah i know but the screen won't load
it's just you know it's a different uh
you know it's just a 4g screen now you
know they're up to 7g and it's just like
you know my train my virtual trainer's
face is all pixelated
go for a hike you dumb [ __ ] all right
or don't i'll get all of this [ __ ] i
know i'm gonna get a bunch of [ __ ] i
mean oh my god
there's a dolphin fan that oh my god i
pissed off a dolphin fan
i can't believe it i can't believe he
took time out from [ __ ] deal and coke
in miami to [ __ ] send me an
email i feel very privileged um
all right let's plow ahead here no but
seriously if you want to get the little
gem on the wall
if you think that that's the one that's
going to get you your abs
while you continue see i like to work
out so i can eat anything i want i love
when people say that myself included
i mean who's getting who if you if
you're working out and you eat anything
you want you won't be as fat
as if you weren't working out and you
ate whatever you want but the end of the
day
the end of the [ __ ] day no matter how
much you stand in front of that [ __ ]
mirror
and do your dumb ass [ __ ] workout uh
like you buy you just go
to 7-eleven and get one of those little
six packs of [ __ ] oreo cookies
you just [ __ ] negated all the
calories you you burnt
that's the problem the problem is
you can eat cookies way faster than you
can burn calories
right and you're telling me there's a
god out there that cares
that's what you're telling me um sorry
anyway plowing ahead here i watched uh
i watched thank you to everybody that
suggested all those cool ass french
movies i've started to watch them i
watched laid
diabolique uh le diabolique
miss you um i watched that
great [ __ ] movie i enjoyed it
1955. watch the original there is a
remake
in anglais um oh no i'm glad uh
1996 i think was sharon stone
sharon stone who got [ __ ] out of an
oscar should have won one in casino i
don't know who won that year
but the fact that she didn't win it was
ridiculous i still think you know
i don't know because she showed her uh a
little hoo-ha there
in the previous movie i think she got
punished it's the only reason why i can
see why she didn't win the [ __ ] oscar
for that
um anyway plowing ahead so i watched
that movie i've been sticking with my
french and now got to the point where
like they're
speaking rapidly as long as they're
speaking french words that i know i can
i can like understand
not like word for word but it's kind of
exciting
i've been sticking with that uh duo
lingo for 166 days
i know it's not the same as going over
there and being completely immersed in
it but you know whatever i'm trying
i'm trying whatever let's talk football
everybody
[Music]
the jets versus the browns that's the
game i watched
because i wanted to see the browns make
the playoffs
i think it's [ __ ] really cool that
they're they're finally good
you know and after all of these years
and baker mayfield has led them to 10
victories when was the last time
any quarterback in cleveland got 10
victories i have no [ __ ] idea but i'm
i'm going to say it's i don't think it's
happened since
the ravens were in cleveland the
originals the original cleveland browns
right
um so basically the background of that
game
is if cleveland wins they make the
playoffs if the jets lose
um they've positioned themselves to get
you know one of the top two picks
hopefully a franchise
level quarterback in the first round
so what you want to happen
all right is you you you want the browns
to win the jets to lose so
what happens what do these two teams do
that just cannot torture their fans
enough the jets
with the jets the old and [ __ ] 13
jets are now on a two-game winning
streak dare i
say the hottest team
in the in the in the afc east right now
i'll tell you right now they are the 2
and 13 team that the buffalo bills do
not want to play
these green [ __ ] go out and they
[ __ ] win
they win i'll tell you right now if jim
irsay was running that team that would
not have happened
he would have made sure they tanked the
rest of the [ __ ] season
um he's getting cursed right now the
curser andrew luck
he deliberately tanked that whole
[ __ ] season peyton manning the great
peyton manning hey my neck feels good
now peyton you know for the first time
ever we're actually concerned about an
nfl player's health
and they sat him tanked the rest of the
goddamn season to get andrew luck
right then he hung with you guys and he
said after
a while like wait a minute i went to
stanford i'm knocking this beautiful
brain am i around
[ __ ] this i got my money i'm out of here
that's what you get jeremiah say
you cheating piece of dog [ __ ]
um you know what he's like he's like
that rapist that walks around with the
male feminist button to keep the [ __ ]
[ __ ] off of him i think that's why he
was always going after the patriots
[Music]
weigh their footballs find something
yes people i will never get over that um
anyway so the [ __ ] jets beat the
browns now
in defense of the browns like their
whole receiving core was out
because evidently they all they all got
in a [ __ ] hot tub together with uh
that hot tub guy there from the giants
or something i don't know what happened
but i get it receivers hang out with
receivers linemen hang out with lyman so
they didn't have any of their top
receivers out there
and um now i don't know if they need
help to get into the playoffs i always
get confused
you know if these guys win and they lose
and these team ties then you know they
got an 82 percent chance oh jesus
not another [ __ ] math problem
[ __ ] math math is great if you're
trying to like learn
how to build a bridge or something like
that but as far as coaching football
you know watching the green bay packers
last night
you know they're up six to nothing i
don't know if they missed the first
extra point i'd have no idea but they
score another touchdown against the
titans
right and you know what happens is their
offensive line wears you down
and then henry gets going during the
[ __ ] third quarter and you're in
trouble right so you got to score a lot
of [ __ ] points
they go for a [ __ ] two-point
conversion and don't get it
in the first quarter it's like what's
wrong with being up 13 to nothing
i don't understand that well well you
know it's a good confidence builder that
it's
it you know they did you you say that
you you believe in your offense that
they're going to get the two points
well aren't you also saying like well if
you only get one point then we're only
up by 13. that makes me nervous
because this other team's gonna come
back because there's too much time left
in the game there's also a negative way
of looking at it
but then again you know i went to summer
school almost every year in high school
for math so maybe i'm not as smart
as the i'm telling you this this is some
man bun [ __ ]
analytics are some man bun [ __ ] you got
some people that never played [ __ ]
football
never played sports probably didn't even
get picked in gym class
hung by their underwear from their
[ __ ] locker back before cell phones
and social media
okay treated how smart people were
treated back when i grew up
okay that was a difficult thing about me
is i got treated like a smart kid but it
wasn't because i was smart it's because
i had orange hair
all right so that was that was a very
very confusing time for me
you know hanging from my underwear
screaming but i'm not smart
as the big kids walked away um sorry
that's a different story for a different
podcast
um plowing ahead here
um yeah so the jets went so now the
browns
i think they have to win the rest of the
way out i just love that the [ __ ] new
york giants
are like five and ten or something like
that
and they still have a shot like they
could they could be six and ten
and win their division and make it into
the playoffs
playoffs the record for worst record
i believe is seven and nine
uh the seattle seahawks got in one year
doing that
um something like that or is it nine and
seven
i don't [ __ ] remember how about drew
brees
what do they say he's got 52 broken ribs
something like that he's got 12 broken
ribs and he's in his 40s and he's still
through for 311 yards how [ __ ] insane
is that
and by the way did i call that alvin
kamara guy or what
i told you guys about him early on that
if i played fantasy football i would
have him on my team
what did he do six rushing touchdowns
i'm smart
um no i guessed i watched one game
i watched one game the cowboys knocked
the eagles out
here's something if you're ever playing
against the eagles if somebody on the
cowboys has the number 88 you probably
want to cover them
okay they don't just hand that [ __ ]
number out that's drew pearson's number
michael irvin dez bryant
and that was cd lamp so you got to think
if they gave him 88
that they feel that that guy can do some
significant damage
so you should never guess run should
never guess run right
and i know this because i never played
organized football past the third grade
all right and i tell jokes
um anyway my new england patriots have
the buffalo bills
the 11 and three buffalo bills
against my six and eight new england
patriots
now we need a win here because i want us
to go eight and eight i would love that
to happen
uh we should see we we we we shall see
what happens what is the line the
buffalo bills are favored by
seven points uh this is such a tough
game to pick
you know because i think historically
bill belichick does great
against newer quarterbacks
but um our offense is just [ __ ]
anemic
and josh allen is obviously the real
deal three hundred
he's three fifty was again four thousand
[ __ ] yards
30 touchdowns oh they only put the glam
ones up where the interceptions
huh by the way by the way
uh that packers game last night how
great did aaron rodgers look
i mean that guy he's got to be the
league mvp i don't know what his stats
are last i saw he had 40 touchdowns and
four interceptions i mean
what what the [ __ ] else could this guy
be doing other than playing defense
starting both ways tackling people um
that's the only only thing he hasn't
done this year
is is on one of those four interceptions
is
tackle the guy that intercepted the ball
creating a fumble and the packers get it
back i think that's the only thing he
hasn't accomplished this year
so um i'm gonna go s like really hacky
really hacky here i'm going to say
as much as you know my team of course of
course in the nfc
uh west is the tom brady buccaneers
the tb buccaneers not tampa bay tom
brady buccaneers of course i'm rooting
for them but i just i
gonna go hacky here i gotta go packers i
think it's gonna be the packers
verse um the kansas city chiefs
only because i just haven't liked the
way the steelers have been playing
lately
big win yesterday coming back or
whatever but i don't know
you know they kind of petered out there
for a couple of weeks
and uh i don't know so i'm gonna go
hacky no surprises i think it's gonna be
the chiefs first the packers
and i think the packers are gonna beat
them that's what i say and then the
packers are gonna
win super bowl number five last night
you know was great
al michael said they were title town and
they show they go the great vince
lombardi when they showed him in their
ring of honor whatever they call it out
there
they said uh he won super bowl one and
two and i was screaming at the tv
and he also won five [ __ ] nfl titles
he won
three in a row
the last team to win three championships
in a row
in the nfl was the green bay packers
all right 66 67 and they also won in 61
and 62.
and they won the it wasn't a super bowl
he won an
afl nfl championship game it wasn't
called the super bowl
until super bowl three and then the
first two games were then retroactively
called the super bowl
all right it's some nerd [ __ ] it [ __ ]
annoys me
but i gotta say it how about tom brady
putting up 47 points
against the lions all right i know what
you're going to say like oh you know
they was playing the lions yeah well
yeah
exactly it wasn't 27 he put up the 47
that he should have put up had 348
[ __ ] yards
20 22 for 27 four touchdowns amazing
so um i think the patriots take a loss
tonight
i think we do i'm gonna be rooting like
hell for them um but i'm actually
excited
for bills fans i like that they're good
and
um you know god knows that they've been
through a ton of
a ton of [ __ ] a ton of [ __ ] [ __ ] so
uh you know i still don't think they're
good enough to win a [ __ ] super bowl
but it is good to see
you know this has just been kind of the
most fun year i've had in a long time
because my team
they don't suck we're just sort of
middle of the pack so now i don't have
to pay attention to all of these other
games because we're out of it being like
[ __ ] ah [ __ ] the cardinals lost to the
49ers come on
i like the cardinals how about the
dolphins
the raiders after winning against the
jets a game they shouldn't have [ __ ]
won
they then lose to the dolphins something
about them playing the afc east this
week this year i should say
it's been [ __ ] weird and all of a
sudden the bears have an offense
bengals put up 37 points it's a weird
day yesterday people
win money did you win any money i would
have lost my [ __ ] shirt
um and then you would have to look at my
pasty chest and no one wants to see that
sorry people why are you babbling so
long about football i don't have any
advertising reads it's the end of the
year
everybody knows you tapped out you spent
all your [ __ ] cash
and you're saving up money saving up
money to bribe your way in
to take the vaccine all right
hey i'm telling you guys i'm gonna get
some sort of hollywood inside
thing i gotta have something you know i
don't want to throw my [ __ ]
half a celebrity dick on the table here
but i did do i love the 80s strikes back
on vh1
okay and i feel like that
you know as much as they try to say that
mtv show was the beginning of reality
television i i think that those
vh1 shows were with the beginning of the
comment shows
and i was a part of that history so i
think i can use that card
to try to get myself in i'd say
two or three million semi-famous people
after george clooney i think i can get
in there and then all you guys have to
do is just listen to my podcast
and if you find any sort of weird change
or i could just be [ __ ] with you
i could start complimenting joe biden
and donald trump
that's when you know that they put
something extra in there
wasn't the white house big enough that
they could like share the white house
like why can't there be a republican
and a democrat in there and then you
just have a libertarian just standing in
between
them going you guys come on we're all
americans here
couldn't that work i don't know all
right
let's do some reads here oh my god oh my
god
i [ __ ] pissed this [ __ ] dolphin
fan off oh by the way did you guys have
a nice christmas
huh did you have a nice chanukah
kwanzaa whatever you celebrate i had a
great i had the perfect christmas
other than you know we couldn't have any
family over um
uh i as a dad i got perfect dad gifts i
got socks i got t-shirts and i got a new
pair of sneakers perfect
perfect i didn't get anything else
that's all i got
and that's all i [ __ ] need as i've
said before like
it's it's about kids um
so anyway my i gave the bike to my
daughter
she loved it totally freaked out had it
hidden
you know and i told her after she opened
all her gifts i said listen uh santa
claus sent me a text message and she's
immediately like listen like yeah
i was like yeah he had one other thing
for you and uh it was kind of hard to
rap
so i had to hide it under a blanket
somewhere in this room
she started looking around and then she
found it she was like a green bicycle
no way freak it out so
um i told her i had to take the petals
off
and i was explaining to her the ideology
that i
that i uh bought into and as i'm telling
her that she puts her eyebrows down and
she's looking down at the floor and
she's shaking her head no
and i'm like what's the matter buddy
she's like i i want you to put the
pedals back on
i'm like i can't buddy it's going to be
too much
we'll just you know do the whatever the
[ __ ] whatever they call those bikes
now a glider
a [ __ ] walker a push bike that's a
push bike right
you just got to learn how to push it
first she's like i don't want to do it
and all of this [ __ ] so we go out to the
driveway
and one of her aunties had bought her a
push bike that she never liked
because she liked her tricycle because
she liked to pedal
so i finally got her on it and she's
like she didn't want to do it she kept
going whoa
whoa and just like not wanting to do it
and then telling me to put the pedals
on her green bike which i eventually did
and she tried it and
it was too much um but i got her to go
back and forth in that thing and me and
my wife really complimented her so i'm
i'm buying in
and i'm actually kind of seeing uh
already that i was probably wrong like
most of the times when i'm flipping out
that uh rather than branding this thing
as an ideology or maybe
it's just a smarter way to learn how to
ride a bike maybe it is
i don't know so uh but at this point i
i bought into it whether i like it or
not so i gotta go with it
um so we're gonna get out there if it's
not raining too bad over the next couple
of days
and um i'm gonna get her uh
get her up and running but i'm
definitely gonna get some
you know knee pads elbow pads and
that old school rollerblade [ __ ] you got
the wrist guards all of that stuff so
she'll be okay just because i don't know
i don't know all right because i came up
with training wheels we already know
this bill we already know this you
talked about on the last podcast [ __ ]
relax sorry can i get
i've already teased enough times about
this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] dolphin fan
um i kind of forget how long the
patriots were good
kicking the [ __ ] out of people in uh the
afc east but
it's all in this guy's email um
so i was teasing dolphins fans saying
that the reason why they haven't won a
super bowl in so long is because
they live in the past and that 72
dolphins team
is rooting against all these kids like
at this point
50 years younger than them to lose
every year so that they can hold on to
their records so
um anyway so i've been teasing about
that so this is what this guy writes he
writes suck a dick
you new england and he tried to write
douche but he
spelt it d-o-u-c-h
[Music]
safe to say this guy
is not part of the analytics crew for
the miami dolphins
uh he wrote we capital w.e
we knocked your cheating asses
out of the playoffs feels great
swallow might come you [ __ ] and then he
writes
all football fans in the world
that's how successful the new england
patriots are thank you very much sir
for that wonderful uh tip of the cap to
the new england patriots as much as i
know you're sitting there thinking that
that somehow hurt my feelings
all i'm seeing is how much
we've been kicking your ass for two
straight decades
through three presidents all right
we have been kicking your [ __ ] miami
dolphins ass
actually you guys have been actually you
guys actually did pretty good with us
we seem to be splitting it but whatever
you would never win a [ __ ] division
so i get it you're a miserable football
fan
i've been there
up until uh drew bledsoe and bill
parcells
you know we were always sort of the
laughingstock although chuck fairbanks
very underrated the team that he put
together in the 70s
roughing the passer call [ __ ] us out
of that victory against the raiders
you know which is why deflategate was a
nice payback
uh not deflategate what was it uh i
lost on the whole gate things wasn't
deflate gate wasn't spy gate
uh tuck gate is that what they called
that one they were all gates whenever
the patriots won it was all gates
you cheated you did this well
considering this this uh
narrative keeps going i hate to do this
to miami all the miami dolphins fans but
i got to get this guy
uh tampergate 1970
don schuler the dolphins committed
three counts of tampering in order to
hire what he was known as
as double dealing don schuler as their
coach in 1970 double dealing dawn
was still the coach of the baltimore
colts at the end of the 1969 season
when then miami owner joe robbie
approached him and signed shula to a
contract you can't do that that's
cheating
uh victim was the indianapolis colts
they were the baltimore colts then
were they punished yes they were the
punishment is as a punishment for this
cheating incident the baltimore colts
were awarded the dolphins 1971 first
round draft picked
as well as the 1972 perfect season was
permanently tainted with
and unofficially appended with an
asterisk this is what they did back in
the day to indicate that the team
cheated
over time people forgot about it and all
they talk about you know which is the
same thing that will happen for the
patriots
all of this silliness all right whatever
i mean because i gotta be honest with
you
all right as much as i wanna stick it to
this [ __ ] guy this immature [ __ ]
i'm gonna be the biggest person here
bigger person here and say that all
right
don schuler was already out
okay and he wanted to make sure that he
landed on his [ __ ] feet
all right and don schuler at that point
was considered a loser
and the fact that he lost super bowl
three was [ __ ] brutal
[ __ ] brutal that was like an xfl
team defeating an nfl team back then
okay and they lost
all right i mean obviously if they put
john united in earlier
they probably would have won the game
considering how great he just walked out
there and just took over the [ __ ]
game but they went with her immoral
um so anyway i think he was going to
leave anyways
you know so whatever they you know
they're guilty of a little country
you know but that was to get a [ __ ]
coach
all right so
i mean if you want to say
that that's not as bad as as the colts
you know weighing the patriots footballs
and then finding that some of the colts
footballs were also
lighter for some reason people never
bring that up but here's an interesting
fact about those
that undefeated uh 1972 dolphins team
okay here's a fun fact all right in 1972
the dolphins drew what most experts
considered one of the softest nfl
schedules ever
their opponents had a winning percentage
of just
357 and they faced only two teams
who ended the season over 500
while feasting on nine teams who ended
under fine
500. so there you go
there you go buddy right back at you
with the cheating [ __ ]
um but i got a tip
i got to tip my cap to the 1972 miami
dolphins nobody
has gone undefeated since them and you
know what else has never happened since
a miami dolphins team hasn't won a
championship
either so there you go by the way we won
six
maybe you should cheat again and get
yourself another [ __ ] coach
um oh god
all the fans in the world that's
hilarious all right fat shaming
billy blaster uh
congratulations on the mandalorian
oh thank you everyone i know is like did
you see bill's performance in mando
holy [ __ ] dude can act well i appreciate
that because i usually just get [ __ ]
i usually just get [ __ ] to be honest
with you um anyways
you put capital s uh there was a female
singer who posted a picture of another
female singer
on her instagram stories who has gained
some weight during covet
the singer who gained weight had a
broken arm
the one who posted asked the question in
her next post
do you think gravy poured out of her arm
when it broke
just wondering if you think you could
get away with the joke like that
and yes i already know the answer to
that question women supporting women
love you love the podcast and happy new
year
um i i probably couldn't get away with
it
saying that about her i could probably
do it on my podcast because i just say a
bunch of ridiculous [ __ ] here
um but um
i would say uh i'm surprised she didn't
get [ __ ] for that
maybe because it's [ __ ] funny um
and plus also like i would i'd be
psyched if i put on weight and i broke
my arm and somebody said that about me
like because that [ __ ] i don't that just
motivates me
you know it's weird negativity motivates
me and like
positively positively positivity makes
me
uncomfortable like when uh when i was
coming up
as a comedian if i walked into a hell
room and the host was like oh my god
this crowd's the [ __ ] where's blah
blah blah
i always had good sets because i i just
was just like
i was a combination of [ __ ] these people
and also like well i mean everybody else
bombed so
there's no pressure but if i would go
and be oh my god this crowd's great
you're gonna [ __ ] kill it
i'd be like you know all my doubt would
be like no i'm not
i'm not good enough it would all go like
that you know
um that's a funny [ __ ] line though
you think gravy poured out of him i'll
tell you the way i ate over the last
couple of days i'm surprised gravy isn't
pouring out of meat thank god i've been
eating my salad a day
helps keep the blubber away
um okay well thank you very much
by the way for that uh saying that stuff
about my acting you know it's nice to
get accolades for that [ __ ] i've been
trying to get better at it for a long
[ __ ] time here all right
[ __ ] neighbor canada oh everybody's got
one
i have a [ __ ] [ __ ] living right next
door to me
all right i'd like to [ __ ] murder him
i i can't tell you what rhymes with that
and something that is only three
i don't want to say that right hey billy
neat freak
i am i am in canada go habs
oh canadian fans hey dude how about how
about [ __ ]
the nhl coming back is it january 13th
or january 16th
and one of the first games they have is
the flyers first the penguins i can't
[ __ ] wait i can't [ __ ] wait they
get a triple header that day i'll be
watching every game
um i have a disrespectful [ __ ] neighbor
of course you do you're up there where
all canadian fans are
um as far as i know they are renting the
house and i believe there are two
separate units in this house
upstairs and downstairs i have only said
hi to these people and don't care to go
much further than that in this
neighborly relationship that's always
smart
uh we have weekly garbage and recycling
pickup where i live
which is likely similar similar to most
but this also means
i have weekly trash pickup in my yard
these [ __ ] next door choose to leave
their garbage and recycle bins
on their front steps completely exposed
to the wind
which inevitably only blows one way into
my yard
their trash rarely makes it into these
bins
uh though as they believe
their front yard backyard and driveway
are the best place for their
drive-through greasy discards
you lost me there oh they're just
throwing [ __ ] into their yard i
continually pick up what lands in my
yard and beyond
clearly i miss a fair amount that blows
right through
and eventually down to someone else's
problem and eventually the water
we all know the story there my question
do i approach these [ __ ]
and ask them to clean up their act that
may be an easy yes
so if it is a yes what if it continues
after i approach them which is my
presumption that it will
yeah i mean
i i i don't know i don't know what i
would do like when you get to that level
of [ __ ] stupid
you know and the fact that they're
comfortable just living in their filth
um i'll finish reading this i think i
already have how i would
handle this uh if all else fails or if i
choose
to go this route in the first place uh
send along some legal ideas
to discretely mess with them without
much thought i've come up with the
obvious cranking music late at night
which will obviously mess with other
neighbors
or taking all the garbage that ends up
my lawn and throwing it in their
backyard
but that will go nowhere and just repeat
the cycle with no winners
both ideas are very discreet not very
discreet either my patience only goes so
far
before it boils over and i'm trying to
work on that myself
but this is one where i don't think
i if i don't think this one through i
may end up over there
with an urge to yell uh you know what it
is
uh thanks um
this is what i would do okay there's
those people are not raised right
they're [ __ ] animals and
the best possible scenario for those
people
because they're walking out it's not
like they're setting the trash
cans out there without a lid on and then
they go in and they sleep and then they
get up late and they don't see that as
blown around
you're saying that they walk past trash
in their yard
anyway and they're fine with it so best
case scenario those people at the very
least
are those [ __ ] people that not when
they rent something
they don't treat it with respect and
they actually
like actually to treat it with
disrespect because it's not theirs
they beat on it you know like a rental
car
um so if i was you what i would do
i would just i mean i'm a [ __ ]
lunatic when it comes to like [ __ ] like
that so i would just
i would just pick it all up i pick it
all up and if they ever saw me doing it
you know if i'm in their yard and
they're just walking by whatever they
say to me that's how i would react
i would just laugh and be like you know
i was gonna ask you to do this but you
walk by it every day so i know it
doesn't bother you
you know and then maybe call him an
animal i don't know but then he just
gets going
like i i don't
like i i there's no the thing about when
you're dealing with that level of level
of ignorance there's no way to win
those people win in life but their
punishment
is their life and you have to somehow
that that's what it is you just have to
take peace in that
okay and if it really gets out of
[ __ ] control
um
i i i can't rat people out i would just
say to him like listen do you guys mind
just
picking up the yard a little bit because
it's kind of blowing into my yard
and just see how they are if they're
[ __ ] about it
then i would just be like listen i don't
want to complain to your landlord
i don't want to be that guy all right
but i also i'm not your [ __ ] cleaning
lady here
can you pick up your stuff see and it's
where's that gonna go
where does it go what are the are they
gonna somehow become like responsible
um empathetic adults
i hate to say this dude you're living
next to animals they're [ __ ] animals
okay and you just have to you know
i don't know you got to have some sort
of peace knowing that none of their
dreams will come true
that's the best like the trash in the
yard
is like it it's a it represents
who they are as people all right does
that work
i feel for you man i can tell you that i
feel for you because that would [ __ ]
drive me up the wall but what i would do
is i would i would just go into the yard
and i would [ __ ] make it spotless i
would just clean it up
i would just clean it up and i would
just say like listen i'm sorry i'm over
here in your yard and i
i get it you guys don't mind living like
animals but i can't live like this
i can't live like this i don't know who
raised you but i'm sorry
for whatever happened to you during your
childhood that you lived like this i
would just go like that like positive
sarcastic
and you know i'd call you a landlord but
i don't want to rat people out so i'm
just over here doing this but i just
want you to know that like
i have no respect for you whatsoever
have a nice day maybe just go like that
just a big smile on your face like i
can't believe you're an adult
i mean look at this you know
you you you got you know there's the a
brain there's the b
brain and then there's the brain that
you got
right i know you can't help this
and really take a look at this yard
because this is the best your life's
ever going to be
then then what are they going to do
start throwing punches then you got to
fight some [ __ ]
jerk off next door i don't know
this there's uh there's a lot of mental
energy
to live next to somebody like that oh
god i actually
you know as much as i like this subject
but this actually i i kind of
i've lived next to people like this is
bringing up some bad [ __ ] memories i
used to just
i would just handle this [ __ ] like when
i lived with [ __ ] messy roommates
i would just come home you know after
being on the road
and i remember my two of my roommates
were in a fight
you know the silent i took out the trash
last time
you know blah blah blah blah this dumb
stupid [ __ ] it's about respect [ __ ]
and i came in and they were both out and
i just cleaned up the whole [ __ ]
apartment and i didn't say a [ __ ]
word
and then one of them finally said like
hey did you clean up all in here
i was like yeah man i can't i can't
[ __ ] live like that and then then
they sort of
behaved like adults but whenever i would
go on the road
i'd come back and they were back to
acting like [ __ ] kids again
but i never felt like i remember a long
time ago i went to a
uh a college football game
and it was this weird sort of deal where
it was my group of friends
and this other group of friends and one
of our friends knew the other group and
we were sort of like sharing the house
and everybody was just [ __ ] like
animals it was empty beer cans and just
[ __ ] all over the [ __ ] place
and i came in and i immediately i just
made the kitchen [ __ ] spotless
and one of the other guys was just like
go out
you didn't have to [ __ ] do that i
said yeah dude i did i'm an adult i'm
not [ __ ] i'm not going to try to make
a sandwich
when this this like you know had like
like like a quarter of a beer left
with cigarette butts in it it's like
yeah dude i'm not living like an animal
when i'm out here all right i was raised
right
and that was it and then everybody just
started throwing out their [ __ ]
empties
maybe you can do that maybe you can try
and lead by example
you know just go out and clean up their
[ __ ] yard when they come walking out
like you know what are you doing
dude i can't live like this i can't live
like this this
this little effect this affects your
whole day
you're living in squalor maybe you go
that route
like buddy don't you want to win in life
this isn't how you win
you gotta attack the [ __ ] day you
don't just [ __ ]
throw [ __ ] into the wind come on man
you're better than this
try to amp them up go over there with a
coach's hat and a whistle i don't know
what to tell you dude
other than i feel for you um but you
know
maybe they won't be there forever
um or maybe you can buy some trash lids
trash can lids
maybe you can do that maybe you just do
that
and then when they go to put out the
trash all you have to do you walk over
you just put the [ __ ] lids on their
[ __ ] trash cans
i don't know just you know what why
don't you just look at it like this
they're children you live next to
[ __ ] children and you just have to be
the adult
one of the worst things about being
adult is all the times you have to be a
bigger person
and i think this is just one of those
times it is
you know i wish it was like the movies
where you could go over there like
steven seagal and give him a [ __ ]
roundhouse
you know if you knew how to do that [ __ ]
or whatever whatever [ __ ]
karate he knows you know but then you
get sued
the next thing you know you're renting
right
well i i this i think this is the most
effort i've ever put into a [ __ ]
answer i'm trying to i'm trying to give
you as many options as possible but like
i know i think i kind of i like i like
to going over i like thinking out of
all the [ __ ] i just said i think i
like the going over there
and just being positive come on man you
can't live like this
just do go that way you're better than
this [ __ ] i mean
don't you want to own a house someday
don't you want did you want to meet a
beautiful woman
and have a respect you and want to have
kids with you start a family
and wake up every day looking at it like
i can't believe i'm married to that
don't don't you want that
how the [ __ ] you gonna get there living
in a junkyard
come on man precious time is passing
all right salads here we go oh people
sending me salad recipes
you guys are this is [ __ ] great all
right
salad dear billy the fish i suggest
buying italian tuna
i don't eat tuna i don't eat tuna
because they're getting fished out of
the sea
and i want the sharks to have something
to eat other than me when i [ __ ] wade
into the ocean with my little
[ __ ] pinkish white toes uh packed in
olive oil not water
and throwing that on your salad i'll do
that every once in a while i try to go
easy on fish man
i eat man-made salmon that's what i eat
man-made salmon i let the bears eat the
the [ __ ] wild salmon
uh you don't know what they're gonna do
uh drain the oil out of the can as you
would
water and stir it around the salad it's
a great way
uh it's a great way to up your salads
proteins and heartiness if you don't
have any chicken on hand
number two hey billy salad bar i'm a 24
year old
line cook on a salad station at a
michelin restaurant
michelin yes like the tires for some
reason they also rate restaurants
i forget how that worked i think the
michelin book was initially
wasn't it like oh it had to do with if
you got these tires you could go on the
road and these are great places to eat i
think that that's how it all started
um anyway a michelin restaurant in new
york
in new york i studied nutrition in
college i think i have a couple salad
recipes
that can suck the fat right out of your
mind
here's a couple of rules slash
guidelines to follow oh my god this is
priceless
salads are the [ __ ] as long as you know
how to balance acidity
salt and fat add enough salt
until it's it is seasoned if you can
taste the salt you've added too much
oops okay uh the trick
to it the trick it
to uh i think the trick to it is to add
just enough to enhance the flavor
of whatever you're cooking without
overpowering your palate yeah that's
too much salt is the worst only use
diamond crystal
kosher salt brand that's in a red box
pour the salt in a cereal size bowl and
keep it on the counter
always season your food with your hands
never from a shaker or a grinder
or grinder top container i wonder why
that is
uh add enough lemon to balance the
fattiness of the olive oil
i just bought a bunch of lemons too you
can think of
the acidity fat ratio as a drum kit
acidity is a high-pitched symbol and the
fat is a deep base
you want them to be complementing each
other is it so is it a 50 50
oh add enough so i got to taste it okay
okay all right um
okay and have them complimenting each
other not have one playing louder than
the other
always taste as you're mixing it to see
what it needs more of
before you finish it so you can actually
enjoy it another good rule is to buy
vegetables that taste good
you don't have to make salads that are
just leafy vegetables
you can make a shaved fennel apple salad
with walnuts and it wins every time
here's some of my favorite favorite no
recipe recipes that i make often
um you want me to read these to you guys
or should i post them i think posting it
would be better
he has a i can't even read it's radishes
ratatouille r-a-d-i-c-c-h-i-o granny
sliced salad
ratio cut into one piano charred
brussels sprouts salad i like the sound
of chard
sweet potato mashed salad six sweet
potatoes roasted
whole in the oven until tender half a
cup
of chopped sauerkraut i'm a german i
love sauerkraut
three quarter cup chopped hazelnuts
sherry vinegar to taste usually two
tablespoons
half a cup of chopped dates put a little
sweetness in there
one package of thinly sliced sliced
chives
salt fresh black pepper that sounds
amazing
olive oil roast six whole sweet six
sweet potatoes until tender let cool
take the skins off and scoop the flesh
into a nice big bowl
add the chopped sauerkraut nuts dates
vinegar chives salt pepper and olive oil
and toss
season to taste this recipe these
recipes were inspired by two of my
favorite all-time
cookbooks superiority burger cookbook
and z zahav z-a-h-a-v
cookbook both have tons of great salads
that are super easy to
make at home as well of tons of
vegetable sides that are actually good
let me know what you think they're fatty
hey man i can't thank you enough for
that and that guy's literally going to
prolong
my life if i stick to these and also
improve the quality of it so thank you
very much
um and by the way to all the other
dolphin fans who aren't
[ __ ] out there congratulations on your
amazing victory this week okay and i
hope you do win a super bowl i don't
give a [ __ ]
um all right obscure albums dear billy
redcunt
come on man um i'm a big
17 year old from
mazel t masalton
m-a-z-a-t-l-a-n
mazatlan mexico and now i'm living
in the inland empire all i do is listen
to music from what i've heard from your
podca
and from what i've heard from your
podcast we almost have the same taste in
music and appreciation for music
um all right obscure albums
these are so obscure i can't even
[ __ ]
i don't even can't even read the names
of these
all right he says 9876 so he has
nine albums here
i don't know how to read this it's e-g-e
then a new word b-a-m-y-a-s-i
by can c-a-n cam was a psychedelic rock
band from the early 70s with a mix of
funk and jazz they're always ahead of
their time
this album has some of the best drumming
i've heard the drummer is
jackie lee bizet
uh this is just a badass band all right
there's another
one called uh 3 47 est like eastern
standard time
by clatto 1976 clatto made this album
and people thought the beatles got back
together with a different name it ended
up just being three guys that wanted to
keep their
identities a secret they got a lot of
backlash because of the beatles hoax and
never recovered from it besides all the
[ __ ] this album
really is really good and could totally
see why all these dumbasses
dumbass people confuse them for the
beatles number seven
dangerous charms by the del monas
the del monas was an all-female british
garage rock band
although they're playing is not too
impressive i love their 60s surfy
rocks sound with their deep bass sound
that sounds like a cool band all right
sister on tour by sister
rosetta stone i think you might know who
she is i don't
but if you don't res sister rosetta
stone is known as the godmother of rock
her guitar playing
from the late 40s to the 60s was way
ahead of its time
oh this came out in 1961. she's been
overlooked by so many people
and overshadowed by chuck berry elvis
and little richard even though all three
of them have said she was one of the
their biggest influences growing up this
album shows more of a rebellious side
unlike her slower commerce soul and
gospel albums which are
still beautiful to listen to it shows
how badass
of a guitar player she really was and
her powerful voice just makes it
ten times better oh man i gotta check
that out
um oh speaking of that
don't you hate when somebody dies that
you should have been into and you should
have seen him live
uh leslie west from the band mountain
and i knew mississippi queen and you
know their hits and stuff
but i never realized everybody always
say oh man that guy's so [ __ ] great
on guitar
you know he died questlove i follow him
on instagram he
mentioned how he died and this breakbeat
that
him and a bunch of his friends used to
sample from um
the live audio when mountain played
woodstock which i didn't know they
played it they got cut out of the film
but they released the album uh
from that set the live album and his
playing is just [ __ ]
unbelievable tone is incredible just an
absolute beast
so i appreciate all of this
all of these bands here that you're
telling me about all right i'm not going
to read all of these
i'll just you guys can check out these
albums number five nader by les
les variations 1969 l ritual by
l ritual a psychedelic mexican rock band
how do you not love that 1971
long lived the new flesh by flesh for
lulu 1987.
uh in his opinion the most overlooked
band of the 80s
i don't know how much much about their
past albums
but this album is everything you want in
a gothic new wave album this guy's like
taste is all over the place too
are you in or out by the growlers 2009
they're not too obscure but overlooked
by so many people the growlers are kind
of a weird band to bring up now because
they were flooded with sexual harassment
claims but my opinion if you base
what you watch and listen to in these
things
you have to stop watching so many movies
because who knows how many [ __ ] win
i don't know whatever maybe they make
good music all right number one
niandra lades and usually
just a t-shirt by john frusciante
oh the chili peppers guy not too many
people listen to john frusciante's solo
music
and people get turned off with this
album especially
uh john wrote this album in his home and
he was [ __ ] up on heroin the whole
time i can see why people get turned off
by the album with songs like
uh your [ __ ] glued to a building on
fire is the name of a song
and horrible vocals but i find it
interesting to listen to
out to what was on his mind when he was
so gone on heroin i could see why
most people wouldn't like it though well
you are definitely open-minded all right
all right what are we doing here
we overnight we're over an hour and i
still got a couple more
questions here all right my kids are
gonna be up soon so
thank you for that salads obscure albums
i mean what the [ __ ] else do you want
here
all right best drama hey there bill
name's chris
a greek from athens living in toronto
because of
what banker [ __ ] in the eu did to my
country back in 08 to 2010.
i hear you often speak about your
favorite drummers but never
have you i heard you speak of nick mason
from pink floyd was wondering what your
thoughts
are here if you haven't heard anything i
suggest you listen to pink floyd's
seasons in pompei italy try to listen to
this
really enjoy the podcast cheers yeah i
love pink floyd dark side of the moon
but i
didn't i never went too deep um
with them but i'm definitely a big fan
you know a nick mason or whatever i just
i don't know i i was never quite all the
way into psychedelic
type of [ __ ] but um
[Music]
i do think that when roger waters and
the whole band was together
um they made some of the greatest albums
of all time without a doubt but like
i also got burned out on pink floyd
because i worked in a warehouse
with these you know guys who played in a
band and were into drugs and [ __ ] and
they played them all the [ __ ] time
and the dead and all of that stuff and
it was just like
you know it was just too druggy it all
just kind of blurred into one [ __ ]
[Music]
jam band for me all right dumb question
for employee
um i haven't said that though gilmore's
one of my favorite guitar players of all
time
uh dumb question for employees uh all
right
this is a segment that we have here
where people write in who have to
interact with the public
this is some of the dumb questions they
ask and as always i always tell this
story i went to the joshua tree
i went to joshua tree and asked a park
ranger where is
the joshua tree so i am i am on the
wrong side of this argument so we're
just having fun with this here all right
dear billy burning beefy bald dome burr
my roommate is a vet tech at an animal
hospital
and has had to close and has had to deal
with a whole different side
of the public their pets it's okay
my roommate is a vet tech at an animal
hospital has had to deal with a whole
different side of the public
their pets it's one thing to have to
deal with people
it's a whole nother thing to have to
and their animals she took the time to
give me the top five dumbest questions
she heard
when it comes to their animal care oh my
god
can my dog get an abortion
[Music]
answer so you want to get her spayed
then
oh no you want to breed her with a
better male
you shouldn't be allowed to own animals
or have children
wow all right number two can you refer
me to a pet
psychic answer uh yes because the
doctor's diagnosis didn't coordinate
with your moon cycle
uh number three can't the doctor just
write me a prescription
without my pet getting getting an exam
answer absolutely the doctor would love
to get arrested today
i would think that the person's actually
trying to get the drugs for themselves
or maybe that's what that joke means um
number four what's wrong with my pet
parentheses after declining all
diagnostic tests and tools
answer uh let me just look into my
crystal ball and guess
based on the fact your dog is not eating
is this what you you want is this why
you want a pet psychic
um at least these snappy answers would
be so much funnier if i could was better
at reading out loud number five
um can my unspayed dog get pregnant
if her unneutered brother mounts her
answer no don't worry incest only
happens in humans
all right thanks for taking the time to
read this love the podcast
um tell bert to go [ __ ] himself bert
what did bert do
um all right that is the podcast
everybody i've been watching my boston
celtics
got [ __ ] destroyed by the brooklyn
nets once again
the brooklynettes who are looking like
they are going to be a force in the east
i'm trying to remain positive with my
celtics i know we have a good squad but
i feel like
we're kind of spinning our wheels where
we kind of every two three years we get
rid of a bunch of people and bring a
bunch more people in
and we seem to then just sort of win the
same amount of games
and can kind of get through the first
two rounds of the playoffs
before getting bounced out so um
i don't know i don't know what kind of
draft picks or whatever we have out
there
uh we shall see but i've actually been
enjoying uh
watching the nba as much as i [ __ ]
[ __ ] about it but then again that's
what i do on this podcast i [ __ ] about
everything all right
um that's the podcast have a great
couple of days i'll check in on you
and go [ __ ] yourselves and uh let's see
i think uh what's today the 28th
29 30 31 oh new year's eve
i'll do a thursday podcast and wish you
a happy new year's eve there
all right i'll see you